okay
for people who are joining this
livestream I am for once not sharing my
screen because I am out walking and I'll
be back at my screen soon but we started
anyway
okay our subject today is qualifiers for
entities and so we have qualifiers like
dated for example that are a way of
restricting the kind of of qualifying an
entity and we have had an idea to
generalize that so can somebody
summarize where we're at in terms of so
this qualified thing you've got written
down here is that something that's
implements or is this a proposal yes
implemented and that's what dated is
based on and support in the key data
data is no it is not yet obviously a
documented fault okay
okay so then qualified what is the
language of what you how you can qualify
things definition so here's a proposal
would it means to qualify an object okay
so is the qualification and you know
when we think about entity queries right
you know we have this entity and then
this value of this property is you know
is defining from a set of entities which
entity do we want to talk about right so
that's one but this is this is a
different thing this is within an entity
this is a sub case of that entity is
that right it is rather making sense it
is reducing which qualify if do you want
to apply to the properties once you
extract some data
for instance the entity visits qualifier
doesn't do anything it only once you
extract for instance the area of a
historic country that changes by date
and there might be other properties that
don't change yeah what we're doing here
is we're attaching a qualifier to the
entity for the sake of saying when you
are proper defied when when we asked for
a property this qualifier should be
transferred to the entity property value
system to determine the correct piece
you know the correct instance of the
property to use is that correct yes I
think that's probably complimentary one
can either say the property is qualified
or the entity is qualified like GDP is
it really the flame of a GDP is it
really a property of the entity the
country or is it also a qualification of
the body so the qualified rapper should
work both for for the entity and for the
property correct yes so for entities or
for instance here's an example they are
first we say the entity we want to
qualify it to say what the form solid
white to one of the properties but any
other property the additional qualified
we saying you want all the temperatures
that means we can mix and match qualify
the entity and the property and there's
a precedent here which takes precedent
it is linked and what when it returns
the data structure which has multiple
things in it what is the so is it is it
like entity what is the the outer layer
of the of the array that's returned is
the outer layer the entity or the outer
layer that's probably it makes the most
sense right if you're returning multiple
entities or multiple instances of an
entity and then multiple instances of a
property there's a question of which way
round you nest it get what I'm saying
did that make sense so
understand okay so look if we ended up
with if there was an alloy there first
okay
yeah and that alloy and we we for that
alloy it had different you know
percentages of aluminum or something
right so which are not different
entities but as somehow qualifying the
properties then and then we asked for
then we have another wrapper around its
property saying give me all temperatures
what I'm saying is which order does that
go in laboratory because in the end it
all applies to the property values no I
I understand that but I'm saying when
you return the results right it's going
to be nested it's got to be a list
there's a nested list right because it's
going to be a nested list for the entity
qualifier and for the property qualifier
and then just trying to clarify what
yeah you know go ahead so so first of
all they have two types of qualifiers
one-step categorical that means you pick
either solid or liquid yeah
or range qualifiers like wall or between
dead and dead and say give me a sample
like a table specification yes and and
then you get back for the qualifiers
that for which you want to range you get
all of those I understand but what about
an interpolating function yes
so for instance if you state date goes
to all you're saying you probably want a
time series which is some qualified
values based interpretation that you can
well i uncertain so we have a bunch of
functions that say which allow you to
explicitly request time series right
yeah and and rather than the all thing I
mean don't we have functions okay so
what does all me okay so there's all on
this time series
and there might also be an interpolating
function as the function of temperature
or something right yes sorry I don't
think that's quite right yes we might
have times yes but at the time series
are made up from individual data points
and then if the sync is an interpolating
function on it oh then it's typically
itself a property value my god okay but
don't you think that we would ever
synthesize an interpreting function from
values yes the framework supports
returning any kind of structure that you
would like so in the simplest version is
you just have those disconnected
qualified values but you could choose a
new structure like a qualified value
array now that handles interpolation or
that allows you to specify how to
interpolate between values why isn't
that just an interpolating function why
don't we just return it up just like we
returned time series why don't just
return an interpolating function or I
mean an alternatively I think we could
do this but we should do it by default
because interpret a involved to make two
strong assumptions about when you can
interpolate for this continuous what's
not continuous for sure well as a time
series does I mean a time series you
know I think it's the same story I mean
there are things where it's reasonable
to do that that's right um but I think
we should make that decision whatever
okay so what is this qualified value
yeah so so we have those two
complementary symbols or at least
support also that on the input we have a
qualifier selector where we either give
explicit values or arrange specification
by call and then the return value if the
value is uniquely determined then it's
just a value but if you say what if me
for all available temperature and that
can be interpreted bending one
implementational then we need to qualify
all of the possible values
and qualify to value there are issues
with this like that the advantage is it
is a nice construct to have really meta
information around something the
disadvantage is it is not immediately
usable well no I would make it usable I
mean but but the problem is you know for
each one of these there's kind of a I
mean in the case of the temperature
dependence right I mean okay so
basically what will come out as a
function of some kind okay hold on hold
on so so let's look at this from earlier
said it might be totally categorical
there's no reason to assume B when you
speak about normals yes I realize okay
so but but you're saying so that could
be an association I mean it could end up
there are different forms you could want
a categorical thing with tagged with
something as an association could want
you know you could want a variety of
things um let's see
but but okay also there's the question
of what the when you say temperature
Arawak what kind of a thing is that
temperature qualifier and each property
can define their own qualifiers for
instance we can look at an example here
now for instance the heart anatomical
structure has a mast qualifiers of the
mast property and it's statistical group
and then we can look up the possible
categorical values of that GUI request
for those different statistical groups
[Music]
but what if what if there was a
distribution of masses that we could get
out that will be a different attribute
or a different qualifier or what I think
would come out it would be own property
I don't think we assemble it on the fly
okay
but is it a property versus an attribute
because some of these things it's like
you know for the temperatures and then
you say give me the mean temperature
that's an attribute in the yes well but
but look if I say I want the mass of
such and such other the electrical
resistivity of such and such a thing at
200 kelvins right but actually I'd be
happy with the nearest you know with the
value we have for the nearest
temperature 200 you can do whatever you
like okay but that's some kind of
attribute like like taking the mean
value right taking you know across all
the values I could just want the mean I
could want the maximum I could want the
minimum I could want the statistical
distribution etc right and to me that's
what we've usually referred to as an
attribute you know entity property value
and then attribute
I mean we asked for temperatures you
know yes how do we get those those are
in weather data requesting you know the
argument that we get what's the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
population date just a single property
name it gives the date was running today
no but look look look look look
you've got these annotations which are
these things where what am I trying to
say you've got these things where you
say temperature arrow whatever now there
also is an annotation version of that
which says at what temperature was this
measured so what I'm saying
[Music]
right right so that's an annotation but
so this qualifier is it using the same
language as the you know is it using the
same language as the as the qualifiers
it's routed for a given qualifier it
can't have a default value okay debt
default qualifier where you can be
stored and retrieved okay okay okay I
finally made it out of the woods as they
say yes we hear some signs of
civilization to pick on right so now I
just have to figure out where I am and
then I'm in good shape just one second
excuse me the good news is I'm able to
do the meeting the bad news is I have no
idea where okay okay good good okay
right
[Music]
okay keep going
see her so sorry alright so so that the
language so given an entity there is a
question what qualifies does it support
that's first question right given an
entity you know it's like entity
qualifiers would be it's like entity
properties would be the the properties
that the entity has but it comes down to
what Stephen said after the earlier
discussion the entity has the property
okay so fine so it has the entity there
is a notion of entity qualifiers and
there's a notion of entity property
qualifiers yes or do logically
semantically right now we don't have
formally diversion of entity qualifiers
so what do you do do you say qualifiers
of an entity this is the step that we
couldn't lead to Intel is what I'm
saying
I see okay so let me see so this is
rather embarrassing right this was a
consequence of having a meeting set that
I thought was in between one meeting
that I was having another meeting and so
I thought that I had ample time that if
I went out in a particular direction
that I would have a whole meetings worth
of time to go back but my other meeting
was canceled when I didn't know it so
okay so what okay all right keep going
[Music]
so okay so then we've got a notion of so
we've got this notion of qualifiers um
[Music]
okay so for any given entity there's a
list of all its qualifiers which are
what are they strings or are they some
kind of entity qualifier object or
property qualifier object so they're
strings but I think they should have
some kind of properly encrusted version
as well yes originally we had or and we
still have an entity property which has
a type name and a property name and
eventually some qualifier that means the
type is a string and the a string and
the qualifier is also a string but they
all encapsulated in the entity property
and the proposal is that we liberate
those qualifiers from the motion of an
entity property and make them available
to other things which are not entity
properties like entity so like qualifier
yes two entities for external identifier
[Music]
okay the problem with a pure naked
string is very hard to document and you
know I mean I can see that we can alike
we should all something which isn't just
a string property
what do you mean their properties the
qualifier like temperature is a property
no it's something different it's an
entity property look temperature is not
the temperature of tungsten isn't a
meaningful property right it's a
different kind of thing so it shouldn't
be tagged as a property it should be
tagged as a qualifier right I mean it
could be tagged as a property qualifier
or just a qualifier taken out of context
okay explore you you put two things
tungsten and temperature together
there's of course no reason that they
would fit together no I understand that
but I want I want to specify tungsten at
a temperature of 3000 degrees
what's its resistivity you mean the
statement was its resistivity yes yeah I
think it's horrible I think that's a no
I feel like that the handful of
qualifiers that apply very generically
like you have to think you can say then
you have it stated we could in principle
say BR you haven't object pitch me a few
positions to say it is there but we
don't have basic equivalent of Dayton
they are there the second argument would
be a geo position and then there are a
handful of other that's how many
substance and then temperature would be
another one in this kind of and another
one would be maybe shape you know there
yeah handful of very durable ones no I
agree I agree I mean these are you know
in physics version of this how do we
think about these that is I mean what is
our what is our way of understanding
what's going on from a kind of a you
know sort of a physics point of view
about this like space and time we kind
of understand those are a thing in
physics but um you know it's less
obvious something like shape is
certainly not a thing in physics
temperature is a thing in physics and a
base unit and all that kind of thing I
mean there's all the depends on the
entity if the entity is very material
and unique like a city many of them
don't make sense to object if it becomes
possible well okay right so and
similarly time like gold
unless it's early in the history of the
universe where it's isotopic abundances
were different but that's very like
secure you know in a first approximation
its time invariant right I mean just
like you can't say I want you know 25
kilograms of New York so I mean the
basic property depends on it it might
still be a sensible state to state
there's a certain amount of gold was at
a certain time at a certain place you
know it's still a sensible statement to
make okay but statement is different
from okay so let's distinguish those
things yeah okay so what we're talking
about is one thing is generically one
kilogram of gold and the other thing is
more the assertion the kilogram of gold
that is at this position that is in the
Federal Reserve you know the Bank of New
York or something whatever it is the UM
[Music]
is that also some kind of assertion
that's also the assertion theta is one
well you mean if I set up Florencia more
something for which no kilogram has
never been produced right I mean about
slightly different but I feel like
there's not such a big difference
between the two I don't agree with you I
think that the the statement that I mean
because the properties of a kilogram
ransom are presumably computable in some
way um and what am I trying to say um it
feels different from even something like
like debate debate with depends where
you're yes it does yes it does well
that's interesting I mean we don't
probably have a weight to property for
things we only have a mass property I
suspect Coit yes abundance of gold 50
years what's that Dooney maybe it's
called to the quantifiable chemistry
this quantification it's a pity the word
quantifier has been used in in you know
for all there exists and so on yes
that's a bit confusing to say
we had long discussions about this like
the one that we use internally was from
alpha s quantity of [ __ ]
very descriptive but not on to begin
naming conventions all right well I mean
quantify is a bit a little bit weird but
but let's sum okay let's not obsess
about the name right now but basically
the point is this is a way of saying no
we discussed this like several years ago
I mean the whole the whole I thought we
had entity I mean just like in the
family of entity group don't we have an
entity but what do we have right we have
to do this job right now but people
thinking if we really want to go into
chemistry and make a ministry reasonably
accessible and natural that having an
entity instant of something versus
osmolality having an entity instance of
this in the certain amount they feel not
very natural well but what's the what
what the alternative here I noticed I'm
what why is it entity instance I mean
you know like name or like concept so
well the name has the problem that I
don't the name so for a loss occasion
you know if the first argument is not an
entity if the first argument is a
molecule or some other object then that
would that was my only okay I mean I
[Music]
mean we could call it like quantity
instance or something that's not quite
right either but we can come up with a
name I quantified it's not gonna work
no dbv did think so it was but I mean
you know there's conceivably qualified
instance quantified instance
or quantity instance I'm not sure
quantified instance is better than
quantified okay so in any case I mean
let's imagine it's quantified instance
for now okay so I don't know what
chemical solution means but that's a
didn't mean I don't know what this I
mean I mean I don't know how we you know
that we'll have some complicated story
about how much water how much you know
hydrochloric acid um sorry doubt it's
just gonna look like that um and I also
think is very interesting social
security properties of you know a
chemical solution of chemical solutions
so to speak but Bakic but you trust at
least your first of your objection is
[Music]
[Music]
what if there was that molarity has to
be specific to the substance mainly
indefinitely that's what I'm saying yeah
in general I mean it's not of chemical
solution yeah mmm I agree but reaching
in from the outside and saying it's
such-and-such and molarity is basically
just a convenience because if the
solution has three components its going
to give an error I
[Music]
does that make sense yeah okay all right
so then all right so we have qualified
instance and quantified instance and
conceptually we're qualified instance
means it's a little weird I mean so okay
right now we have entity instance an
entity instances tries to handle both of
those things correct yes okay
so you want to break them apart because
you want to put things other than
entities in the first argument is that
correct yes okay I mean we could just
call it an instance and but it's all
made very nicely this faint instance
well fair enough okay okay whatever I
mean but the the basic point is that
what you want to do is you want to have
just like with entity instance you have
a grab bag of things that qualify its
properties or you know if it's something
like a chemical solution they reach in
and specify options to that thing I mean
it's a little bit like show yeah okay so
I mean instanced well I think that
sounds like too much like
object-oriented programming but
basically what we're saying is I mean
then then it could be axiomatic that
anything you can do with this outer
wrapper
you could also insert into the objects
themselves is that a true statement or
is that not a true statement it's not a
true statement for an entity is it not
right now for entities okay so for
entities it's always still the wrapper
is outside it an entity instance wrapper
is outside it
order yes um okay when we could imagine
that that's what ok so then then this
show like construct can put ok why do we
want the show like contract what is the
point of it
so for each thing we also have like
entity okay we have entity incidents
could potentially have property instance
right that is the analog of qualified
but but what you're saying is so
property instance could have property
instance could have whatever okay okay
let's let's zoom out a little bit so
dated has has been very nice yeah I
think so what we want to do is
generalize the success of dated and but
dated is in a sense unnecessary because
everything you can do with dated you can
do with annotations right yep now the
thing I'm not clear with dated is this
exception of some of the dated units but
what does that mean what dated units I
mean so dated comma all has the stack
that it returns time series right no I
mean I need ad which isn't the entity I
[Music]
see okay but but but okay the dated
comma all hack which is highly useful
right let's talk about that in its
generalization because can I say I can't
say data to comma mean or you know I
could say dated come on all and it gives
a time series right so similarly if I'm
saying um you know I don't know
qualified
well see look if I want it as a function
of temperature density as a function of
temperature I would say something like
qualified you know density comma what am
i doing how am i doing that I'm saying
something like how am i saying that as a
function of temperature
I want the density as a function of
temperature and you voided sewa default
from the Basel day there's a long list
of values I could take either of them
but it's one no how I guess it's all
[Music]
decision it's up to the designer of that
density property to decide what the
possible right hand sides are no no no
we've got to have a standardization of
that yeah for instance one approach
would be if we say all then in the case
of categorical values then the choice is
career all of them and in the case in
finite set of possible values
[Music]
well I don't necessarily agree I mean I
think even in the case look we can make
a decision okay time series what we
don't have an interpolating function
unlike okay time series has this notion
of dateless plot to plot it and we can
say mean of a time series we can't say
mean of an interpolating function it's a
different kind of thing um I mean we
could invent a thing which is like a
time series but it's not as a function
of time it's as a function of some other
property right so it we could imagine
something where we say just like we have
all kinds of things for dealing with
Time series duration etcetera etcetera
you know we could imagine something
where it is as a function of some other
essentially physical property position
temperature whatever else yes am I
making sense yeah
but it wouldn't be so much different
from an interpolating Falcon no it's not
so different but it but it but it has
the feature I agree I agree we might be
able to you know do it in terms of an
interpolating function I'm not sure um
[Music]
it's a little bit like quantity of a in
array of quantities yes yes it is
yes it is um okay so all right so let's
come back again to how you select out so
I mean there's two things there's I want
to select the value for tungsten at
temperature whatever and I want to get
the results as a function of temperature
how do I get those two things knowing
that in most cases the data we have will
be incomplete with respect to you know
[Music]
did you get what I'm saying I think so
so two possible ways either you have
hundred explicit values and you just
want to get them or you will have a
computation and you want to compute and
get it in maybe an interpolating
function for certain range of
temperatures yes in the Christmas how do
you specify that other than odd it could
be a span or something more
sophisticated right right so what have
we done with historical countries you
know that's still an unsolved thing we
say there's this country and we want to
get its border in 1652
okay and I think we have a mechanism and
is there anybody here who knows about
that is Alan here yeah I'm here I mean
we've just been using
dated to specify that on whatever the
property is in dated of polygons
whatever the year is I see and so we
don't have a mechanism for a span of
years we don't have any notion of a geo
interpolation I mean so that's like time
series is an interpolation of a value I
mean so so I think we have we have we
have all we have a we have a set of
discrete polygons for some set of years
while that country was in existence but
no notion of interpolating those things
okay so I mean and then then also coming
with geostatistics will probably be an
ability to interpolate spatially as in
we know the density of foxes you know in
this region or something we can
interpolate something about that or I
don't know I don't even know whether
these things you know sometimes I look
at it sometimes they won't
[Music]
hmm okay
okay so you're saying all right so let's
go back again to all right so there is
qualified that I mean so first of all
how do you do the discovery to get a map
of what's there so given an entity I
want to know
well given an entity and a property I
guess I want to know what are all the
qualifications what all the places for
which we have values with respect to all
the qualifiers there to understand the
question properties of properties okay
[Music]
all right you know what what do I know
it for example for gender there that's
bad choice but I mean you know it's like
what can I choose
so I'm saying yes for the categorical
qualifiers you can get the list for the
non categorical there's at the moment no
indication of what you can do once it's
for date you might be able to give an
interval or yeah I think an interval is
the right thing for enough okay so then
here I mean I don't like the fact that
these are so many naked strings
[Music]
especially when some of these things
mean there where it says you know
Mexican Nicaraguan etc etcetera etcetera
um you know whatever [ __ ] direction do
you want them to be wrapped in something
like well if I obey you or do you want
them to be entities
well I'm thinking closer to entities I
think but there might be wrong I mean
you know an entity which is the
qualifier value of whatever I mean that
might be the wrong idea I just think
that this is right so then not
concentrate by what it has to be they
can be entities so that was data
modeling choice and not a friend actress
the from X of thoughts having entities
here instead of those strings okay but
so what about what I want to say middle
school middle age or preschool if I want
to say do I have a whole syntax for age
of thing alternatives thing how does
that work and then how do i distinguish
whether I want the list of results or
the aggregate of the results yes so at
the moment
[Music]
you would basically construct different
properties yeah and then you have some
entity but so you can't
there isn't a syntax that says HRO
middle age vertical bar school age yes
and the syntax hasn't been really
necessary yet because you can expand it
out into separate properties no but you
can but you may not want to I mean in
other words yeah if I mean and so how
does this relate to the entity querying
mechanism I mean where we say you know
entity City , you know population arrow
take largest how does it relate to that
yes so that's a class of the largest
populations now but you could say data
in 1915 does that work now in principle
yes we can check in disk
oh yeah particularly it does not at the
moment okay why is that why is that I
mean why does that not I don't
understand isn't that doing a database
query all right there is I don't think
that particular query is translated to
an efficient okay so we should fix that
bug yeah okay
well that's not a horrible syntax I mean
set a dated population arrow take
largest three that's perfectly
reasonable it means yeah okay so what's
the analog of that if I say okay all
right so for example let's say I wanted
to get the three highest temperatures
for which the density of tungsten has
been measured so in other words if I
were to say entity see this is what's so
weird here so I've got an entity and
then I am qualifying that entity not
inside the entity like this but somehow
outside is an entity instance yes I
can't think of a syntax at the moment
for a particular person because it's
it's the values that you put into their
qualifier it's basically asking what are
our possible values that a function can
take yeah basically asking for the
domain in an association that will be
values I mean in so far as an
association is it's discrete function
and you know clearly there should be a
way to get out in the case of this
population versus age there should be a
way to get out an association that says
adult error whatever middle age air or
whatever and so on now one of the tricky
things in that particular example is the
total of all those is an over counting
right because those categories are not
mutually exclusive you see what I'm
saying
[Music]
so sometimes there will be mutual
exclusive and sometimes they will not
and for example knowing that fact might
be yet another qualifier of a qualifier
so to speak yes so when those qualifier
values are entities yeah they can have
all the relations necessary to determine
which ones are orthogonal to each other
and which ones just rotate so we can
mark and then then I would have to go to
another meeting in four minutes okay are
we at time for this meeting in four
minutes I'm sorry I'm just not yeah it's
four minutes before one okay um well
this should clearly be continued let's
let's set up another one of these I mean
I I can we try to set up another one
this week so that we don't have haven't
forgotten everything that's going on and
of course I wasn't able to look at the
comments on the live stream well wait a
second it there yeah okay but weather
weather interesting comments on this
live students are worth bringing out
here
I didn't further it they see oh dear
okay well sorry to everybody there when
the next meeting will be paying full
attention maybe we'll be able to address
this the tail end of this I'll be back
in that eye
what a goof up okay um all right so then
okay so did you have a summary 'we had
written down what all of thee what all
the proposed structures actually are so
you've got it's basically the qualified
qualified value and quantified so those
are the three things you're proposing
yes and the qualified could also be
called qualifying select or right yeah
there's more work to be done on this I
mean let's just understand I mean the
scenarios
okay I mean just like this dated they're
sort of geo placed is another concept
that we could imagine yes what else
could we imagine that is a similar
generic rapper I mean there's there's
physical amount yeah heat it what
temperature this shaped what why are you
so obsessed with shaped is that for food
I mean when the know it could speak to
you you were it only alpha yes you
always wanted like falling speed of
various shaped objects in secret I see
okay fine but I mean I mean the problem
is now that we have a whole
computational geometry system you know
shaped it's like I don't really quite
get the shaped one because I think that
we are they're describing
qualitatively of it's roughly a you know
a capsule shape or something all we're
describing it quantitatively in terms of
you know region objects and things yes I
mean basically something very steep this
region in given the region that
describes the shape how do I think you
guys need to go but we should continue
this but please let's continue it before
we've kind of forgotten what's going on
here yep okay for people following this
live stream we will be continuing with a
live stream by a slightly different
topic but maybe at the beginning of that
one will try and look at a few comments
from from this one and let's see I mean
anything else we need to cover right now
thank you okay that's some wrap this up
back on a different live stream soon
okay see y'all soon
[Music]